the memory palace is a technique to
remember facts numbers or other things
like a shopping list it has been around
since ancient times and is also known as
the method of loci memory champion
Marwin Vilonia s-- used it to remember
in just 30 minutes
the correct order of 5040 binary digits
and a complete deck of 52 cards in just
33 seconds here is how it works close
your eyes and imagine some sort of
familiar physical space like your house
school or office and then add a mental
image of the thing you want to remember
to remember a bunch of things you can
use different rooms and visualize how
you would walk through that space
following the same specific route as you
walk through place the things you want
to remember at specific locations
ideally imagining things in a funny or
crazy way also helps to remember once we
have placed all items that we want to
remember our memory palace is complete
the day we returned to our palace and
want to remember what's inside it we
have to go back in we have to
concentrate and imagine opening the door
and walking our route once we pass by
the specific location that we use to
place our thing the item will pop back
into our minds let's try to remember 7
ingredients to make some pancakes one
you open the door and see a full cup of
flour next to some shoes to you walk
into the bedroom inside your bed sleeps
a teaspoon full of baking powder 3 in
the living room sits a massive egg
watching TV 4 and on top of the TV is a
cup of milk
five you go into the kitchen and see six
teaspoons dancing around a bottle of
vegetable oil six you leave the house
and enter the garden but it's full of
sugar canes and in the middle a teaspoon
dressed like a gardener seven you turn
around to check the bathroom the only
thing left is half a teaspoon and salt
now try yourself close your eyes and
think of a familiar place such as your
home
we will now slowly list seven numbers as
you walk through your space place each
one in a different location let's go
314
one five nine two six now revisit your
palace then write in the comments below
what you can remember by the way if you
want to memorize Pi or something else
for a longer time forget this technique
turn off your screen and start
nothing beats are learning by doing
[Music]